So let's look at the write-update
snooping coherence first,
let's look at two caches only, each of
which has two blocks, with a single
valid bit per block in the tag, and
then the data, and both of these caches
are connected to the same bus,
to which we also connect the memory.
So now let's say that the caches
are initially empty, so
the value bits are all zero, and this
processor reads something in block A.
We have a cache miss here,
we send the request to memory.
This cache is always monitoring
what's going on, on the bus, but
it's only interested in writes.
So this read is really going to be
seen and ignored by this cache.
The data for A comes back from memory
and now we put this block in the cache,
and the block becomes valid and
the title message just indicates
that's this is the block A.
Now let's say that this
processor writes to A.
So now we have a situation,
where this processor,
even if it does a write through
access directly to memory,
a read on this processor would
still read the stale value of A.
Let's say that the value
we read here was 0.
Now let's say that this
processor writes 1 to A.
This write, even if we made
it go all the way to memory,
would not result in coherent
behavior for this cache,
because a subsequent read here will
still hit in the cache and get the 0.
So this is when write update and
snooping come into the picture.
We have a cache miss, but
because it's a write we send
a request for the block along with
an indication that it's a write, and
what is the value and
what's the address.
So now what happens is this request goes
to memory, and the memory writes 1 to A.
But more importantly this cache
is monitoring the bus and
sees that block A is being updated.
It checks its internal state and
sees that it has block A, and
then it takes the value
that is being written.
So this part is the snooping part where
we see what's going on on the bus.
So we cannot miss any of the writes
happening on another core,
because we are monitoring the bus, and
all writes have to go through the bus.
That's the snooping part.
The right update part is
that when we see a write,
we update our copy of the data with
the value that is being written.
So this cache now gets a 1 here,
if we read A after this,
we're going to get this one, so
this ensures correct behavior.
If there are multiple cores, they can
not disagree about which right happened
first, which one happened last because
all of the rights are sent through
the bus and because it's a single
brotecuz bus, it happens one at a time.
So all of them see rights,
in exactly the same order, in the order
in which writes go to the bus.
Now let's see what happens
if both of these processors
tried to write to A at
about the same time.
So this is a situation where they
might disagree about whose write
happened first.
Let's say that this one
is trying to write 2 and
this one is trying to write 3.
Well there is a single bus, so there
is a single set of wires that can carry
the value and the address and so on.
So processors, when they want
to send something on the bus,
first have to arbitrate for
it, and this arbitration for
the bus basically decides
who gets the bus next.
If this core won,
then it sends its write first,
now both of the caches will have two.
This one because this is
where the write happened.
This one because this is what
we pick up from snooping, and
only then, after this is complete,
this right here gets to occur, so
now we go to 3, broadcast that here,
and it gets here.
So as you can see, both of them
agree which write was first and
which was second.
Obviously, the one that
wrote 3 was the second one,
because that's the last value we kept.
So the write update is
ensuring that writes are seen
by reads on all cores, and
the snooping of the common bus and
the serialization on that bus, basically
going one at a time to the bus is
guaranteeing that everybody
sees the same order of writes.